WE WILL REBUILD THE DEMOCRATS
AND THE MEDIA ARE REALLY
ATTEMPTING WITH THIS BARR
HEARING.
BUT FIRST, I WANT YOU TO
UNDERSTAND THE MOST CRUCIAL PART
OF BARR SENATE TESTIMONY AND
TELLS US WHERE WE ARE GOING TO
THE NEXT SEVERAL MONTHS AND
BEYOND ALL THAT FAKE OUTRAGE
OVER BOB MUELLER.
DISAGREEING WITH BARR'S SUMMARY
OR WITHOUT THE SUMMARY AND
SLANDEROUS ATTACKS ON THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TODAY.
THIS IS THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
TO NOTE.
>> WE FIRST HEARD THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL'S DECISION TO NOT DECIDE
OBSTRUCTION ISSUE WOULD MEET
MARCH 5TH MEETING WHEN HE CAME
OVER TO THE DEPARTMENT.
AND WE WERE FRANKLY SURPRISED
THAT THEY WERE NOT GOING TO
REACH A DECISION ON OBSTRUCTION.
AND WE ASKED THEM A LOT ABOUT
THE REASONING BEHIND THIS.
AND THE BASIS FOR THIS.
SPECIAL COUNSEL MUELLER STATED
THREE TIMES TO US IN THAT
MEETING IN RESPONSE TO OUR
QUESTIONS THAT HE EMPHATICALLY
WAS NOT SAYING THAT FOR THE OLC
OPINION HE WOULD HAVE FOUND
OBSTRUCTION.
>> Laura: OKAY, THIS IS
STUNNING.
WHILE ALL THIS MEANS IS DESPITE
ALL OF THE CHATTER AND CALL A
SUB, HAIR PULLING TODAY, DESPITE
THE CONTINUING LEAKS, MUELLER
WAS UNABLE TO FIND OBSTRUCTION
AND FURTHER THIS JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT MET THE LONG-STANDING
OPINIONS FROM THE OLC.
A SITTING PRESIDENT CANNOT BE
INDICTED AND NO BEARING ON
MUELLER'S FINDINGS.
NOTICE THAT THE LEGAL GENIUSES
OVER AT OVER AT MSNBC DID NOT
INTERRUPT THEIR LIVE COVERAGE OF
THE HEARING TO HIGHLIGHT WHAT I
JUST SHARED WITH YOU.
BECAUSE THEY WERE TOO BUSY DOING
FANTASTICAL REAL-TIME FACT
CHECKS, WHICH I WILL SHOW YOU IN
JUST A MOMENT.
BUT THIS WAS MY FAVORITE
DESCRIPTION OF THE DAY.
>> SPECIAL COUNSEL INVESTIGATION
STARTED BY HANDPICKED DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
>> I WILL CONTINUE TO HEAR FROM
THE PRESIDENT'S HANDPICKED
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
>> TRUMP HANDPICKED
ATTORNEY GENERAL WILLIAM BARR.
>> MISBEHAVIOR BY HANDPICKED
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
WORKING FOR HIM, NOT THE
COUNTRY.
>> Laura: WAIT A SECOND, WAS
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION SUPPOSED TO BE
PICKED BY NANCY PELOSI AND
CHUCK SCHUMER?
WHAT WOULD THEY PREFER A
RANDOMLY SELECTED SOMEONE OFF OF
THE STREET OR MAYBE GO TO THE
LOTTERY SYSTEM INSTEAD.
EVERY ATTORNEY GENERAL IS
SELECTED BY THE SITTING
PRESIDENT.
HE SERVES AT THE PLEASURE OF THE
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM.
AND THESE OTHER MEDIA OUTLETS,
THEY DON'T KNOW THEIR BASIC
GOVERNMENT FUNCTIONING, I GUESS,
JUST FOOLISHNESS.
AND THE MEDIA WERE NOT ALONE IN
THEIR SLANDEROUS ATTACK ON BARR
OF COURSE, HAVING DETERMINED
THERE WAS NO TRUMP RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE MOVED ON TO A
TROMP FORMAT COLLUSION NARRATIVE
TROMP FORMAT COLLUSION NARRATIV.
>> I THINK PARTIALLY THAT
CONCLUSION IS INESCAPABLE.
>> YOU'VE NOT ONLY PUT YOUR OWN
QUESTION BUILT -- GIVING
SANCTION TO BEHAVIOR TO THE
LANGUAGE THAT YOU USE IN THAT
PRESS CONFERENCE YOU HELD.
>> YOU LIED, AND NOW WE KNOW.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES A SACRED TRUST.
YOU HAVE A TRAIT THAT TRUST
AMERICA DESERVES BETTER.
YOU SHOULD RESIGN.
>> TO SLANDER THIS MAN FROM TOP
TO BOTTOM.
>> Laura: SENATOR GRAHAM,
COURSE 100% CORRECT.
IF THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO IMPEACH
THIS PRESIDENT ON THE BASIS OF
THIS MUELLER REPORT, I SAY, YOU
TRY.
YOU GO FOR IT, KIDS.
YOU HAVE THE WHOLE REPORT.
YOU HAVE ALL 448 PAGES.
NONE OF THE DEMOCRATS, BY THE
WAY, HAVE GONE TO VIEW THE FULLY
UNREDACTED REPORT.
THEY CAN GO, THEY CAN GO TO THE
SPECIAL JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IF
THEY ARE SO UPSET ABOUT AND SET
ON THIS IDEA OF IMPEACHING
TROMP, GO LOOK ON THE FULL
REPORT OF UNREDACTED.
THE ONLY PEOPLE BOTH
REPUBLICANS.
THESE PEOPLE ARE COMPLETE AND
UTTER FRAUDS.
IF YOU THINK YOU HAVE THE
EVIDENCE TO IMPEACH, ROLL THE
DICE.
LET'S SEE WHAT YOU GOT, GUYS.
LET'S SEE WHAT YOU HAVE.
LET'S SEE WHERE IT ENDS UP HERE
IN THE MIDST OF THIS HARASSMENT
TODAY, BARR EXPLAINS HOW THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL PROCESS ACTUALLY
WORKS.
>> HIS WORK CONCLUDED WHEN HE
SENT HIS REPORT TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
AT THAT POINT, IT WAS MY BABY.
AND I WAS MAKING A DECISION AS
TO WHETHER OR NOT TO MAKE IT
PUBLIC.
AND I EFFECTIVELY OVERRODE THE
REGULATIONS USED DISCRETION TO
GLEAN AS FAR FORWARD AS I COULD
TO MAKE THAT PUBLIC.
IT WAS MY DECISION HOW AND WHEN
TO MAKE IT PUBLIC, NOT BOB
MUELLER'S.
THE JOB OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS NOW OVER.
THAT DETERMINES WHETHER OR NOT
THERE IS A CRIME.
THE REPORT IS NOW IN THE HANDS
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
EVERYONE CAN DECIDE FOR
THEMSELVES.
THERE IS AN ELECTION IN 18
MONTHS.
THAT IS THE DEMOCRATIC PROCESS,
BUT WE ARE OUT OF IT.
WE HAVE TO STOP USING THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE PROCESS HAS A
POLITICAL WEAPON.
>> Laura: BINGO!
THAT WAS THE KEY MOMENT FROM
TODAY.
BY THE WAY, PARTICULARLY NO
CRIMINAL WRONGDOING DISCOVERED
BY MUELLER.
ZERO!
HE COULDN'T DO THE INTERVIEW
WITH THE PRESIDENT.
HE DIDN'T WANT TO GO TO COURT TO
SIT DOWN WITH THE PRESIDENT
BECAUSE HE KNEW HE WOULD LOSE.
SO LET'S BREAK THIS DOWN FOR
SOME OF THE ARMED CHAIR LEGAL
ANALYST OUT THERE.
THERE IS NO DISAGREEMENT ABOUT
THE CENTRAL FACT OF MUELLER'S
INVESTIGATION.
FACT ONE, THERE WAS NO CRIMINAL
CONSPIRACY WITH RUSSIA.
SOME PEOPLE CALL THAT COLLUSION,
NONE.
IN FACT TWO, THE MUELLER REPORT
DID FIND POSSIBLE INSTANCES OF
OBSTRUCTIVE BEHAVIOR, IT DID NOT
COME TO A CONCLUSION TO
RECOMMEND EXECUTION, A BINARY
CHOICE EITHER THERE OR APPEAR
THE OTHER WINDOW DRESSING.
THE INCONSEQUENTIAL RANTINGS OF
FANATICS WHO DID NOT GET WHAT
THEY WANTED AND THEY ARE BITTER
AND THEY ARE CLINGING TO THE OLD